لا شيء يشغلهم اليوم اكثر من الانتخابات
لا صوت لهم فيها لكنهم حديثها حديث يقف
عنده اللاجئون في تركيا ليترقبوا مصيرهم
فقد دفعت بهم حسابات الجوله الثانيه من
السباق الرئاسي ليكونوا من اكثر عناوين
دعايهها جدلا يعني كثير كثير مضغوطين
نفسيا متشتتين ما بنعرف ايش نشتغل يعني
يعني نشتغل الا بدنا نترحل ايش المصير
يعني مجهول يعني مضغوطين منذ بدايه الحمله
من كثر التصريحات
مثلا تجرات كبيره معهم السجن نحويه
اموالنا تجمدت قلقين من المستقبل تبعنا ما
بنعرف حالنا لقدام اشي بصير فينا اذا نجح
اي طرف اي حزب مصير كسوريين ما بنعرف وين
[موسيقى]
في سباق الجوله الثانيه وبعدما كان للجوله
الاولى من معطيات
صعد تحالف الشعب معارض خطابه تجاه
اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
تلتها خطابات وصفت بالاكثر تشددا لزعيم
تحالف الشعب المعارض كمالك تجاه اللاجئين
وقد عزم على طردهم اذا وصل الى الحكم
هذا الخطاب دفع اعضاء من حزب المستقبل في
تحالف الشعب المعارض للاستقاله بسبب ما
اعتبروه اهانه للاجئين في تركيا ولان طرد
اللاجئين تصرف غير انساني كما وصفه رئيس
تحالف الجمهور الحاكم رجب طيب اردوغان
فمقاربه تحالفه تقوم على وضع خطه للعوده
الطوعيه الى المناطق الامنه للسوريين
وابقاء اصحاب الكفاءات منهم
من فلاجئين في تركيا لطالما كان مثار جدلا
سياسي طوال سنوات لكن تصدره الماده
الدعائيه الانتخابيه الان لدى تحالف
المعارضه مثير للاستفهام مؤلفات مثل سوريا
احزاب المعارضه تستخدم قضيه اللاجئنا ماده
رئيسيه في دعايتها لكسب اصوات الناخبين
الذين لم يصوتوا في الجوله الاولى اعتقد
ان تحالف الشعبي المعارض لم يقدم عودا
تقنع الناخبين في قضايا رئيسيه مثل
الاقتصاد فركزت دعايته الانتخابيه على
اللاجئين يترقب اللاجئون مصيرهم وقرارات
الفائز في الانتخابات ويترقب غيرهم تبعات
ذلك
اعتقد ان التفكير في ترحيل اللاجئين خصوصا
السوريين امر خاطئ انهم يعملون معنا
ويدفعون الضرائب مثلنا لقد انخفضت وتيره
العمل هنا بعد خشيه السوريين من الترحيل
وعدم معرفه مصيرهم
تختلف نبره الخطاب وحيدته بين تحالف الشعب
المعارض وتحالف الجمهور الحاكم في قضيه
اللاجئين الذين يرون مصيرهم متارجحا بين
وعود المعارضه بترحيلهم ولو قصرا والعوده
الامنه طوعا وفق الحكومه عمر حلب الجزيره
غازي عنتاب جنوبيه تركيا